the queues at pcr testing centres are
long waiting times for processing
results can take days rapid antigen
tests or rats are nearly sold out those
that are available are selling at high
prices every state in australia is now
recording a growing number of cases with
one in five people in new south wales
testing positive
at the moment there does not appear to
be any sign that it's abating the
numbers which are being reported
in terms of positive cases uh clearly an
under reporting of the number of actual
cases out there
that means that a lot of people get
infected very quickly so hopefully that
means we get through the community very
quickly but really to some degree that's
not really the way you should be doing
it over the last week the number of
cases being recorded has climbed to more
than 10 000 a day across australia
in new south wales there are five times
as many people being treated in
hospitals compared to mid-december
queensland recorded its highest number
of daily cases since the outbreak began
so it won't be a surprise at all if in
the next couple of days we see a
significant increase in in cases as more
more samples are tested and more people
come forward so that won't be a surprise
in the next few days if we see a
significant rise in cases
with borders now open across all states
except western australia the spread of
coronavirus is rapid with different
generations mixing over the new year
holiday this is about
tempering or managing the spread it's
not about trying to stop it and
and it's it's
it's an awareness that
whilst we knew ultimately everyone
probably would be exposed to coronavirus
anyway um that this is now sped up that
process so it is really just trying to
manage it particularly while we're still
rolling out the booster doses to the
people who are quite vulnerable
testing centers in some states were
forced to close over the new year due to
high temperatures
that combined with the lack of rapid
antigen tests across australia is
putting the health system under even
more pressure the failure of this is
actually making the pandemic worse and
causing potentially the infection to be
spread much more quickly at the moment
um so we've got this gap
where just when we needed it we don't
have these rapid action tests which is
directly contributing to the chaos
but also the potential for increased
transmission of the virus to the
community
chaos that's unlikely to be averted with
the holiday season still underway
sarah clark al jazeera queensland
australia